bienvenue à tous bienvenue à
bibliothèque médicis l'histoire
l'histoire pour mieux comprendre le
présent même si l'histoire ne se répète
pas l'ouverture des archives révèlent le
caractère et le comportement des grands
acteurs de la deuxième guerre mondiale
hitler churchill roosevelt staline sur
les chefs incontestés pendant les
guerres de leur armée pourtant en
matière de stratégie militaire
il était nulle ou presque nulle disent
les historiens de vrais amateurs la
guerre n'était pas leur métier
françois kersaudy non la guerre n'était
pas leur métier mais il prenait les
décisions suprême en dernier ressort
heureusement il était parfois entouré et
souvent bien entouré et quelquefois ils
peuvent entourer du tout pas autour et
du tout parce que dans certains cas on
le verra tout à l'heure leurs généraux
leurs officiers supérieurs il les avait
mis en prison le seul vrai officier
supérieur le général de gaulle qui a
donné à la france
la résistance la fierté n'a eu aucun
rôle réellement militaire à londres il
échafaude et disent les historiens
toujours des plans stratégiques
d'envergure dont personne ne tenait
compte pour nous français sont heureux
son rôle fut décisif à la fois symbole
de la lutte contre l'occupant et
symboles aussi de la libération du pays
et bien bibliothèque médicis a invité
cinq historiens ou des témoins les plus
remarquables experts de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
jean louis crémieux brilhac merci des
classes est un honneur vous recevoir
pas seulement parce que vous alliez
publié de livre passionnant que j'avais
lu autrefois les français de l'an
quarante ans de volume chez gallimard et
la france libre de l'appel du
juin du général de gaulle à la
libération 96 toujours chez gallimard
vous avez fait partie des forces
françaises libres dès 1941 cette petite
armée gaulliste qui devait acquérir sa
légitimité au cours des combats et dans
la bataille mais parce qu'aussi part et
j'ai envie de dire enfin ceci ce gros
livre un livre qui a été longtemps
interdite de diffusion en france des
anglais dans la résistance qui est écrit
avec michael foot
pourquoi interdire rang on se le demande
c'est un mystère une chose tout à fait
extraordinaire ce livre écrit par un
hangar annan historien anglais de
première classe dans les années 60 à la
demande du gouvernement britannique a
été interdite traduction en france
pendant cinquante ans par le foreign
office
mystère c'est tout à fait incroyable
quoi possible de trop à l'avantagé des
français
naturellement de gaulle on pensait enfin
on suppose que des anglais ont pensé que
de l'application de ce livre sous les
prêts des tempêtes en france et la
colère de de gaulle en montrant que les
anglais jouent un rôle considérable
non pas qu'il passe inaperçu en france 1
il faut pas qu'ils passent inaperçus ils
s'allument ans et ça si je comprends
bien ces deux gouvernements gouvernement
à londres que le foreign office a
interdit la diffusion
oui voilà exactement c'est seulement en
2004 qu'il a été autorisé diffusion en
france offre maurice weiss historiens
respecter réputé je suis content que
vous soyez là vaut aussi pour vos livres
la paix au 20e siècle la puissance où
l'influent chez fayard en 2009
il ya quelques semaines aux éditions
andré versaille sur un autre thème
comment de gaulle fit échouer le putsch
d'alger en avril 1961 c'est les colonels
et généraux challe salons etc
on en parle peut être l'autre jour et
auparavant vous aviez choisi est préfacé
les 50 discours qui ont marqué la
deuxième guerre mondiale
ceux des acteurs dont nous allons parler
et si je comprends bien chaque discours
était un un acte de résistance de
propagande de guerre
certainement pour
les chefs de la deuxième guerre mondiale
parler c'était combattre c'était
transmettre aux populations des
consignes c'étaient les encourager à se
maintenir dans la foi et par conséquent
les discours des chefs de la seconde
guerre mondiale avait un rôle éminemment
politique était écouter naturellement
grâce à la radio
précisément est il touché des centaines
de milliers d'hommes
ça a été le cas pour le moment de
l'invasion de l'union soviétique ça a
été le cas pour le la conquête de la
france libre à elle l'invasion et le
débarquement par conséquent il ya eu
toute une série d'occasions où ses
discours ont joué un rôle considérable
50 y en a eu beaucoup plus un taxi je
reviens ce que vous disiez des textes de
chercher seulement elle a eu combien
2509m en 1785
vous voyez michel est coincé voli font
autorité sur de gaulle et jirau
l'affrontement péter les français sur
l'occupation sur vichy que vous
connaissez mieux que personne et vous
venez d'avoir accès si je puis dire aux
dernières archipel pas qu'il n'avait
encore qui étaient inconnus sur la
période est ce qu'elle révèle beaucoup
depuis elle révéleront beaucoup mais je
pense qui est intéressant c'est pas
seulement la révélation que peut donner
un document parce que souvent bon c'est
un scoop
bien entendu mais il faut leur attaché à
l'histoire générale française ça je
crois que c'est le rôle de l'historien
est ce qui est assez extraordinaire sous
les c'est de voir ressurgir dans cette
période abominable de l'occupation tout
un passé français j'allais dire que
pétain c'est aussi la contre-révolution
ses 1800 4815 1820 c'est bonald ce thème
c'est toute une histoire qui rejaillit
on en parlera
le maréchal pétain fut aussi un des
grands chefs de 14 18 mais aussi l'homme
de l'armistice de 40 de la collaboration
de la résignation
un maréchal qui n'a pas combattu sur le
front pour la deuxième guerre mondiale
tu es bien vieux quand on met de l'état
français jean lopez spécialiste de
l'histoire de l'union soviétique et ses
relations avec l'allemagne du troisième
reich bienvenue vous publié au seuil
grandeurs et misères de l'armée rouge
d'où ce témoignage inédit de vétérans de
l'année 1941 1945
ils détruisent alors oui ils détruisent
le mythe de staline un mythe dont vous
dites qui a été construit à coups de
mensonges on le verra staline qui
revêtait l'uniforme de maréchal n'avait
jamais pu entrer dans l'armée
non il avait été réformé pour une
atrophie du bras et il n'a pas fait il
n'a pas fait son service militaire il
puisqu'il était là continuer ses études
de séminariste puis il est devenu très
vite révolutionnaire professionnel mais
il a il a appris il a appris beaucoup
hein
c'est un homme qui a beaucoup fréquenté
les militaires pendant la guerre civile
entre 18 et 21
et puis après entre 41 45 donc évoluer
dit manquez pas de talent militaire même
ses douze témoins inédit le révèle au le
dit mais en dehors de la guerre
elle-même
il est responsable de la mort de combien
si on le sait d'officiers supérieurs
d'officiers de sa propre armée
le spécialiste de la question le colin
glande etats-unis estiment que 22000
officiers supérieurs soviétiques ont été
passés par les armes entre 1937 et 1941
11 milles environ été interné torture et
relâché brutalement réaffectés à des
postes divers dans l'armée on sait pas
pourquoi il les sortait de tous les
envoyer au combat c'est que c'est
complètement chaotiques comme ce type de
décision la plupart sont très étranges
et le facteur chance qu'a joué on sait
pas bien pourquoi en cause ce qui par
exemple a sauvé sa tête et papote à pof
ne sais pas après avoir passé trois
années en prison
oui y avoir été torturés quasiment
tous les jours celui qui n'avait plus
dans on lui a enlevé toutes les dents il
avait une dentition en faire et il a eu
il a subi 12 simulacre d'exécution et il
a défendu et l'avenue maréchal
soviétique et staline françois kersaudy
bibliothèque médicis vous attend depuis
plusieurs mois vous le savez vous aussi
vous enseignez vous travaillez grâce aux
archives inédites sur le rôle des grands
qui furent les chefs de guerre parfois
sans compétence pour uni expérience
immédiate et vous allez publier toute
une collection chez tallandier ou chez
perrin maître de guerre là vous en
publié 2 1 hitler l'autre
yanis khaddari patton mais on vous doit
beaucoup vous avez contribué à la
résurrection si je puis dire de winston
churchill à travers ses textes réel ses
mémoires
vous avez traduit ses mémoires publié la
biographie qui est là qui nous avait
passionné les rapports de gaulle
roosevelt et maintenant hitler vous êtes
chocolat le meilleur le meilleur
connaisseur de churchill si un
contradicteur boulot dit
mais depuis depuis 30 ans vous êtes son
admirateur oui on peut dire ça et il y
en avait il y en a d'autres
les principaux indices par une balle
ivory valait la peine at war on va le
voir il avait un passé militaire mais
c'était d'abord un politique qu'une fois
au 10 downing street connaissait quand
même peu à la chose militaire
mais si je vous ai bien lui qui a su
s'entourer d'un comité militaire avec un
état-major de grande qualité
oui sur ciel c'était un militaire mais
c'était ils avaient été entraînés formé
à être sous lieutenant de cavalerie donc
les liens torrent de cavalerie on ne
visait pas aux secrets de la stratégie
et par conséquent il est resté
militairement au niveau 2
l'officier du lieutenant dix ans de
cavalerie et un petit peu plus au moins
de la guerre des tranchées donc pendant
la grande guerre
mais il n'est jamais allé au delà et par
conséquent ses conceptions de la
stratégie était celle d'un amateur mais
qui s'est nourri des gens qui l'avaient
choisi pour son état major
ils vivaient là et tu sembles le fameux
bunker souterrain de londres qu'il est
aujourd'hui aussi passionnante visite et
wii / ils sont allés que assez rarement
pendant les bombardements quand on le
visite on nous fait croire qu'ils ont
pratiqué toute la guerre là c'était pas
y faire un nom pas du tout y sont allés
quand les bombardements était vraiment
très dur c'était pas hitler à la
chancellerie de berlin voilà sous la
chancellerie où il a passé et même avant
dans ses quartiers généraux en prusse
orientale hitler était dans les bunkers
saint georges il n'aimait pas les murs
il est comme si je peux combien de
livres c'est signé françois kersaudy je
peux aussi vous écrivez vite mauvais
vous êtes dans la dans la guerre vous
n'êtes pas sorti de la guerre n'est pas
finie pour vous non c'est pas pour ça
c'est un petit peu un hasard c'est parce
que au moment où j'ai commencé à écrire
c'était une période assez faste ce que
les américains faire une fenêtre
d'opportunité c'est à dire la fin des
années 70 où les acteurs ou les grands
témoins étaient encore là et les
archives s'ouvrait et c'est une occasion
qui ne se représente pas parce que si
vous écrivez sur napoléon vous fera des
archives mais vous n'aurez pas les
lieutenants de napoléon c'est ce que
vous avez fait sans doute aussi monsieur
bien sûr lopez avec des survivants quand
il fallait pour enrichir l'histoire du
bien je les connaissais et je me
connaissez tous ma bulle vous étiez
avait que j'étais avec eux mais dans
quatre quarts se dit je voudrais ajouter
qu il est un des rares historiens qui
savent à la fois bien parfaitement
l'anglais et l'allemand
ce qui tue ne combien de langues parlées
vaut mieux car ce dix neuf ce qui est
très peu parce que mon père après 56
vous sortez le hongrie nom de bretagne
pour vos capteurs provocateur et mais
cède pour aller gratter ou découvrir des
derrière les papiers jaunis où les
documents oui oui parce que souvent
quand un affrontement par humble
franco-britannique pour savoir qui a
raison il faut aller dans les archives
néerlandaises norvégiennes
parce qu'il était neutre finalement il
était un spectateur il n'avait aucun
intérêt d'un côté ou de l'autre donc
cessé mais ça peut être très technique
sera essayé de comprendre les uns et les
autres vous pouvez intervenir
naturellement comme chaque fois sur tel
ou tel par exemple pour ouvrir la ronde
des chefs de guerre la route tragique il
ya le grand seigneur est ça ici j'ai eu
une paire le grand seigneur adolf hitler
qui a saigné le continent européen avec
combien de morts sur lopez au total
mesure 50 millions oui entre 50 et 60
est alors un c'est ça monsieur vice
c'est les estimations sont toujours
difficiles à faire et il ya toujours des
contradicteurs
je ne pensais pas un mélange en matière
militaire
hitler scène amateur un petit caporal de
rien du tout d'abord oui et un caporal
qu'il rêve jamais commandé parce qu'en
fait c'était un message jesusa fait par
la première guerre mondiale donc quand
il a parlé de son génie stratégie qui
vient de la grande guerre
on serait un peu parce que en fait il
avait ce qu'on avait une perspective des
tranchées il n'a rien vu il n'a pas
fréquenté le commandement il n'a jamais
commandé ne serait-ce qu'un peloton au
feu et donc devenir le grand chef de
suprême de la wehrmacht à présent
évidemment ça surprend un petit peu il
vivra pratiquement toute la guerre en
méprisant pas mal de ses généraux
touquet et en craignons qu'ils
complotent contre lui absolument
alors ça y ressemble installé sous
staline avait fait le ménage avant la
guerre et ils s'inquiètent un peu de la
montée de certains qui rabaisse de temps
à autre il sait susciter des
concurrences entre derrière des
procédures régulières une généraux
soviétiques se s'arrête en 41 pour en
parler mais en 41 ils arrêtent de
fusiller d'un fusil une vingtaine après
c'est terminé
il ya même une évolution inverse de
celle d'hitler il va vers de plus en
plus de confiance sous contrôle strict
évidemment envers une poignée de ces
deux c'est ma région
tous ces chefs qui se faisait la guerre
on réécrit pas l'histoire mais si il
avait eu des compétences réelles sur
penses tu rates la stratégie militaire
s'il avait écouté plus souvent les leurs
généraux que se serait-il passé
ça dépend lesquels tu as départ légal
hitler aurait été beaucoup plus
redoutable s'il avait écouté et ses
généraux parce qu'il en avait de très
bons auquel ni ne laissait pratiquement
aucune liberté priment dans le cas de
staline effectivement comme vous allez
jusqu en gros jusqu'au milieu de 42 il a
commencé à jusqu'au milieu de 42 il a
voulu imposer sa stratégie il c'est à
dire qui consistait en fait à faire
attaquer partout et l'attaquant qu'à un
moment ça marche
non ça ne marchait plus du tout et donc
c'est là que il a commencé effectivement
à faire confiance à des gens dont
c'était le métier et qui a été très bon
comme joue coffre comme vassili apps qui
des gens comme ça qui eux connaissaient
leur métier maurice 20 professionnels en
ce qui concerne claire il ya
certainement un moment où on a fait
confiance volontairement assez généraux
au point de vue de l'audace c'est au
moment de l'attaqué de la france le 10
mai 40 c il est sûr que à ce moment là
il a mis de côté un plan qui était
préparée de longue date et il a préféré
un plan tout à fait novateur qui a
réussi de façon extraordinaire le
diamètre 40 71 ans presque jour pour
jour le réarmement accéléré de
l'allemagne c'était taux diffère la
modernisation du matériel militaire en
allemagne
c'est hitler l'offensive contre la
france dont viennent parler maurice
weiss l'autriche la pologne la
tchécoslovaquie c'est encore lui les
généraux ne font qu'appliquer ses
décisions il n'a pas de conseillers au
début il ne jamais il n'a jamais eu de
conseiller il avait von manstein qu'il
est là il a trouvé que son plan était
bon pour le reste toutes ces décisions
stratégiques veut
et toutes armées de son cerveau et même
si ses généraux n'étaient pas d'accord
il devait appliquer c'était comme ça et
si je peux me permettre
précisément le fait important dans cette
histoire là c'est que il réussit vous
avez idées les différents coûts des
années prendre le début des années 40
et chaque fois il réussit contre l'avis
de ses généraux si bien que il devient
quelque sorte le génie militaire qu'il
n'est pas comme le dit à mes livres est
un génie pour la conquête du pouvoir
absolument c'est aurélie maléfique est
et pour l'intimidation parce que ces
premières conquêtes l'autriche la
tchécoslovaquie la mutation de rhénanie
c'est de l'intimidation et ça marche
très bien mais l'intimidation même à
l'intérieur quand on voit comment il a
réglé le compte de son ami le rhume et
csa il ya eu combien une mort en
quelques nuits la nuit des longs
couteaux comme ça ça va entre 200 et 250
à peu près
sans compter les victimes collatérales
donc bon si vous permettez sur 100 200
morts pour une purge c'est une
plaisanterie à côté de cet animal ne
s'alliera au sein de son propre peuple
je veux juste apporter à propos des
rapports entre histoire et ses généraux
un petit bémol proposer un hitler
dilettante et stupide de stratégiquement
a dégénéré au gmi omniscient je trouve
que c'est facile parce que tous ces
généraux se sont déchargés de leurs
erreurs après guerre sur hitler en
réalité une analyse assez saine une
réappréciation et qui intervient depuis
une vingtaine d'années montrent que même
manstein ont multiplié les erreurs et
n'avait pas la tête militaire aussi bien
fait qu'on a voulu le dire ils ont été
servis par beaucoup de facteurs au début
de la guerre mais après ils ont quand
même sauvé la situation après c'est allé
manstein a sauvé la situation après
stalingrad parce que pour les stalingrad
les mois qui ont suivi stalingrad sim
einstein n'avait pas été rappelé pour
essayer de contenir les soviétiques
on doit aussi quand même beaucoup à la
passivité de ses adversaires de ceux qui
sont patients on l'a dit monsieur qui a
dit lisa tellement intimidées oui enfin
non je crois que s'ils voulaient pas se
battre sur garros si vous regardez la
situation enfin tout à fait révélatrice
de mars 1936 quand ils occupent la
rhénanie avec des troupes lamentable un
finalement dessau enfin des gens dont
les services de renseignement français
disent qu'ils valent pas grand-chose
suffira d'envoyer deux divisions la
déchire on les avait eus pour les
renverser
mais en face finalement personne ne veut
agir
nos militaires et là c'est le général
gamelin niveau-là lassé des troupes
formidable il dit en chef du
gouvernement qui évidemment profite pour
ne pas agir mais c'est pas vrai nom est
lui-même finalement se raconte des
histoires donc hitler doit beaucoup
aussi à l'abaissement d'un certain
nombre d'armes et où deux chefs d'armée
face à lui alors cherchent ils à propos
de cherche il dit dans les mémoires qui
n'a pas de préjugés d'ordre national
contre hitler je connaissais mal sa
doctrine sa carrière pas du tout son
caractère
et puis j'admire les hommes qui prennent
la défense de leur pays dans la défaite
même si je suis de l'autre bord à un
moment il va se réveiller il va se
rendre compte assez vite du côté
agressif et conquérant
oui avant qu'hitler ne soit hitler il
n'était pas bien connus simplement sur
ce il faisait partie de ces gens qui
avaient lu mein kampf et qui se disait
bon c'est un va être dangereux peut-être
qu'une fois au pouvoir il va se calmer
et il s'est aperçu très rapidement dans
l'un des premiers qu'une fois arrivé au
pouvoir il ne se calmait pas du tout et
par conséquent s'il a été un des
premiers à avertir que là le danger
venait de là et que c'était encore plus
il sera encore plus dangereux que
staline et que donc il fallait des
priorités et ça c'est ce que beaucoup de
gens n'ont pas compris autour de lui
alors les mémoires de churchill
c'est 3000 pages vous l'avez dit si
volume cette année de travail collectif
c'est toute une équipe les anciens
collaborateurs qui travaillent pour lui
si ça oui oui oui c'est une oeuvre
collective mais on on lui préparer le
travail et lui churchill disait
churchill disait ça veut dire qu'on lui
donnait 30 pages sur une question il en
est cette
et elle était géniale il a eu le prix
nobel de littérature en 1953 de
littérature ouais ça lui faire beaucoup
parce que finalement un des grand regret
de churchill c'est de ne pas avoir pu b
difficile enseignement supérieur et
d'avoir vu été envoyée trop jeunes dit
il dans une école militaire
il a une drôle de caractère churchill à
travers les mémoires bon on le situe un
peu si vous voulez les uns les autres
rien affecté apparemment sans morale
même la proximité et la réalité du
conflit qui est en train de vivre
apparemment il fallait pas le déranger
pendant sa sieste quotidien aujourd'hui
ça phénomène c'est un phénomène
décrivait le dégrilleur françois cantin
phénomène parce que pour pour une
demi-douzaine de raisons d'abord comme
d'ailleurs la plupart des gens dont on
va parler au plus haut niveau il a une
mémoire qui fait la hure issement de
tout son entourage mémoire fin d'année
il ya une volonté incroyable
il a toujours eu trois vocations à la
fois la politique
le métier des armes et l'écriture
le discours est un prolongement de
l'écriture et se voit il a vécu de sa
plume hélas oui il a vécu il a vécu
pratiquement que de sa plume le reste
n'étant pas rémunérateur et c'était
quelqu'un qui dictait ses livres et qui
écrivait ses discours et quand il est
dicté ou les textes ou quand il
regardait les notes je l'appris en
lisant votre biographie de churchill il
était souvent dans sa baignoire le le
cigare au bec
oui avec un petit verre de whisky à côté
oui oui oui cependant tout juste la
guerre oui oui
quelquefois il raconte que il est allé
faire la sieste entre 16 heures et 20
heures
ah non une heure et une heure j'ai
jamais plus d'une heure même pas et je
vois vers 16 heures il a dû se réveiller
dit-il père du pop art exceptionnel et
une sieste et les voilà et des voyages
il y aussi marre je le recommande à tout
le monde ce qui était un peu naïve de sa
part voilà il suffit de se mettre au lit
voilà deux semaines en pyjama au lit et
entre 16h et 17h et après on peut aller
jusqu'à 4 heures du matin c'est qu'il
fait il se rendait pas compte que ces
officiers lieu ne pouvait pas se
permettre ce luxe et que par conséquent
quand il les a menés jusqu'à 4 heures du
matin il était en très mauvais état et
encore un trait de son caractère c'est
qu'il est mal et sur le front il allait
sur terre sous l'eau avec des sous
marins à bord des navires
il aller sur le terrain il est très
attiré par le danger traite est un élève
est la guerre ces lettres combattants
arrivent à la différente aline qui s'est
approché une fois du front à 50 km qui
n'a jamais visité les membres tranchés
une fois il a même inventé les écrits
des lettres vont songer à roosevelt et
churchill en leur disant je reviens dix
journées en fait non il ne quittait ni
son palais du kremlin ou sa datcha de
qu'une seconde où j'ai relève de la rue
kirov manager afin d'approcher le moins
possible aussi des est-ce qu'on va
parler de l'admirable bataille
d'angleterre qui a duré 57 nuit il
interrompu sur canal ininterrompue et la
résistance des anglais malgré les
bombardements constants sur londres
avait 10 ans a raflé fille le courage
civique des anglais quelque chose
d'absolument
et on l'a revu à nouveau en 44 au moment
des v1 et v2 puisque les allemands
avaient prévu de détruire londres hitler
est prévu de détruire londres à l'aide
de cv 2 dans les anglais n'avaient pas
connu avant 43 l'existence ni la
technique
qu'est ce qui explique et leur
résistance aux avions de la luftwaffe et
à domicile moi j'ai une grande
admiration pour le civisme anglais il y
a une tradition de courage il n'est pas
été envahie depuis 1066 et le le courage
anglais qui avait été remarquable dans
la guerre de la guerre de 14 18
on oublie trop que les anglais ont joué
un rôle considérable on tue les pertes
énormes
ils ont fait preuve d'un courage
remarquable dans les combats de l'artois
notamment en 14 18
mais le civisme anglais durant la
seconde guerre mondiale a été générale à
quelques exceptions près et l'angleterre
est le seul pays qui a pu se permettre
de mobiliser les femmes pendant la
guerre ce qu'il te reposer mais en même
temps ce que vous montrez bien c'est la
construction d'avions
la formation pilote pendant que hitler
les bombarder churchill est le seul
homme
concevable qu'ils aient pu faire pendant
la première guerre mondiale
construire des tanks par les chantiers
navals et pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale construire des avions par la
manière de la presse les deux fois sa
remarquablement bien marché c'était des
gens qui qui connaissaient leur travail
et qui ont réussi et de la deuxième
guerre mondiale à construire les avions
beaucoup plus vite que les allemandes
étaient capables de les abattre et le
courage des pilotes en plus je crois
aussi quand même que sans diminuer le
sens fort et des vertus extraordinaires
de ce peuple qu'on attende dirait qu'on
admirait tant en france
cette pause quand même le problème
général des bombardements aériens et sur
les populations et de leur efficacité
dans la guerre parce que olivia par
exemple oh oui enfin c'était pas faire
d'allusion récente mais je pensais plus
au grand bombardement qui sont
maintenant très étudié en allemagne on
va c'est chrome on part demanderesse
d'hambourg etc font des dégâts immenses
des dizaines de milliers de morts et
pourtant les gens finalement ne cède pas
contrairement à ce qu'on aurait pu
imaginer ou ce qu'on aurait pu souhaiter
il est vrai aussi si on voit manger un
petit peu le cas français que la défense
passive c'était perfectionner aussi et
que les populations étaient relativement
mieux protégés michel côté nous allons
voir les français nous allons voir
staline encore un peu de de chercher
vous raconter mers-el-kébir le port
d'oran la royal navy cool la flotte
française et winston churchill je vous
racontais avait prévenu d'armand quand
il ya eu une rencontre en france il dit
à dar lancez-vous qu'il racontait il
faudra jamais laisser les les nazis
s'emparer de la flotte française dans la
même ville je suis à 40 40 et d'arles en
fait la promesse mais il a qu'un pas si
la tiens d'ailleurs n'avait aucune
intention de laisser
c est son fief une avait aucune
intention de laisser des allemands
s'emparait de la flotte mais ça les
anglais ne pouvait pas le savoir
et à partir du moment où on refusait les
conditions puissent y en avait six en
fait les jeux l'amiral jean soul n'a
transmis que 2 à brest on sait pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs
et parmi les conditions qui étaient
posées pour laisser la cette partie de
la flotte tranquille si j'ose dire il y
en avait plusieurs qui aurait pu être
acceptée entre le sabordage et le
bombardement qui étaient les deux seuls
été transmis il y en avait un certain
nombre d'autres notamment celle d'amener
la flotte aux antilles ou aux états unis
et il ya une bonne raison à cela c'est
qu'à ce moment là il était hors de
portée des allemands est logé l'amiral
qui transmet sa passe là il est
vichyssois oui il est en tout cas il est
il est anti anglais de toute évidence en
demander à chercher quelle est votre
politique
il répondait à cette faire la guerre ce
qui varie guère sur mer sur terre dans
les airs avec toute la puissance de la
force qui plaira à dieu de nous donner
faire la guerre contre une monstrueuse
tyrannie sans égal dans le cynisme
catalogue du crime humain et quand on
lui demande quel est votre but
le début ses débuts c'est l'inspiration
que les manceaux je le fais la guerre il
est très recherché terre admirateurs de
u2 clemenceau c'est bien on dire pour un
anglais ces grandes idoles c'était
jeanne d'arc napoléon et clemenceau
c'est fabuleux
le but le but quand on lui dit quand on
lui demande quel est votre but
or c'est là c'est là c'est l'annulation
complète d'hitler ce qui me simplifie
beaucoup la tâche
c'est la mort d'hitler et s'est terminée
ce qu'il faut dire quand même aussi pour
essayer de la bataille d'angleterre
c'est que
la luftwaffe n'étaient pas faites
n'avaient pas été conçues pour ce genre
d'opération traverser la manche
des bombardements à long terme sur une
longue période a été conçu pour la
blitzkrieg pour soutenir l'armée
il y avait sur des petites par ailleurs
donc il n'avait pas il n'ya pas d'avion
ravitailleur non en tout cas cherchent
ils
c'est une prose ample on a un peu
insisté sur lui drôle exaltante qui
mérite d'être lu ou relu comme les
mémoires du général de gaulle absolument
dans ce village écrivains conseils
on va en parler est-ce que je peux
revenir sur mercil kebir et vous
contredire un peu cher a dit je ne suis
pas absolument certaine que gensoul
pouvait accepter cet ultimatum
parce que l'armistice était quand même
signé et par ailleurs churchill
peut-être pas lui directement
enfin les anglais avaient quand même été
averti des engagements de saborder la
flotte et de ne pas la donner aux
britanniques
alors ce qu'il ne savait pas si vous
voulez c'est ce qui s'est négocié entre
l'armistice et les jours suivants dans
la rue si stupidement la flotte
française reste dans ses ports d'attaché
du temps de paix donc on peut supposer
qu'il y en aura eu à brest en zone
occupée mais en réalité entre anglais et
français il a été décidé qu'elle serait
dans les ports de la méditerranée
alors je prends quand même que la mersey
le kébir c'est pas aussi simple que ça
mais après il ya des fautes des deux
côtés
parce que on aurait pu négocier parce
que alexandrie on a négocié on a
finalement ont rendu la flüela flotte
est resté alexandrie une négociation
rien n'a pas eu de mers-el-kébir mais
tout le monde est quand même allez un
petit peu vite dans cette affaire et a
été un peu dommageable pour les
relations franco britanniques un peu
quand même pour faire intervenir le
général de gaulle là dedans
vingt ans après il a dit
la place des anglais j'aurais fait ce
qu'ils ont fait mais c'est parce qu'il a
vu sur le coup et laissa général de
gaulle vous l'aviez rencontrer je les
rencontre est assez bas oui il faudrait
pas au moment où on est a fait un
discours où il dormait combat condamnant
l'opération de verser le kébir des mois
de juillet le surlendemain de
l'opération ça a beaucoup ralenti
ralliement dans les camps de deux
soldats français
quand on dit mais bon vous l'avez encore
et il éclate de rire mais aussi par une
forme de commande et de fierté de
modestie nous parce que vous pourriez en
dire plus vous avez connu vous un destin
extraordinaire dans les années 30 qui
peut leur raconter vous étiez en
vacances en allemagne
vous assistez à la montée du nazisme
c'est une atmosphère comment en flammes
électrique et compte deux compères de
combat intérieur d'une pauvreté avant
enfin jusqu'à 31 32 33
une pauvreté qu'on n'imagine pas 6
millions de chômeurs les des gens de
france on emporte toute la journée pour
demander une pièce une tartine de pain
on n'imagine pas ce qui a été le tram de
langue hitler vient les sauver et lm
sauvé et c'est ça et alors j'ai vu tous
mes petits copains les petits copains
que je m'étais fait en allemagne qui
était socialiste à l'époque les uns près
des autres entrées aux jeunesses
hitlériennes
quelquefois à l'insu de leurs parents
mais le prestige le prestige
l'entraînement on était quelque chose
qu'on peut pas mettre nos fédérations
les foules les grands défilés de
nuremberg c'est exact il s'est calé
rentrant thierry et puis une forme de
prospérité plus de la disparition du
chômage des grands travaux qui les
freine tout ce travail est mobilisé en
39 vous êtes prisonnier dans la marne
vous est envoyé en allemagne
cette fois pas en vacances non mais
qu'est ce que vous faites pendant
combien de temps je suis resté six mois
et je me suis dit si j'ose dire barret
ouais en choisissant l'est c'était le
premier coule t réussi à faire illusion
tentative d
dans le premier cas a été réussi une
chance et une chance au jour de l'an 41
donc je me suis évadé vers l'union
soviétique qui n'était qu'à 425
kilomètres de mon camp vous allez vous
allez rejoindre comme en papier comme un
personnage en fait ce chemin de fer oui
non mais le passage de la frontière
naturellement dans la neige les barbelés
des chiens enfin tous les colis dans
l'hérault mort de deux se lient
rencontre l'aventuré sourire comme si
c'était facile mais quel âge à l'époque
22 ans
si vous étiez accompagné d'autres avec
un copain copain ce oui oui parce que
oui et puis ensuite alors l'union
soviétique c'est comment vous accueille
en union solide a été gelée cette mort
l'arrestation lanthier choc du goulag
inculpation de passage illégal de la
frontière et suspicion d'espionnage donc
pris dans pris dans le le flou
d'épuration de la laddh de la lituanie 2
les énormes épuration de la lituanie a
confié d'exécution et de déportations
les trains cellulaire ensuite prison
moscou et et tout cela avec à la fois
l'incertitude et puis une espèce de la
grèce de la jeunesse tout même des peurs
quelquefois des peurs quelques fois où
il a eu des preuves alors sérieuse et
notamment notamment quand quand j'ai été
enfermée dans un dans un cabinet noir de
la prison louis en quarts et puis et
puis une grève de la faim
j'émets une grève de la faim à la prison
boutyrka qui a été brisée durement on
nous en a commencé à nous nourrir par le
nez alors vous serez libéré quand la
france libre deviendra l'allié du
kremlin qui avec 185 autres prisonniers
vous avez rejoint londres et le général
de gaulle et là on vous a pas refermé on
n'a pas dit si on peut être des espions
cuvée de moscou venant si jamais c'est
arrivé tellement d'autres oui et alors
l'arrivée l'arrivée de 186 voix des
français au moment où de vous les open
crise avec churchill
c'était un atout pour de gaulle qui est
exploité notamment l'arrivée est un
petit événement médiatisé que les
souvenirs inuit cette période reste
vivant le voit puis vous saviez ça me
contrer j'avais lu catala et puis de
temps en temps quelques confidences
mais vous en étiez havas autrefois
maintenant nous en donner beaucoup plus
mais nous en attendons mais bien sûr
mais il faut aller le chercher
et alors les vue puisque donc on a parlé
de dollars de l'armée rouge à travers
les barbelés ou deux
les trains cellulaire qui nous ballader
j'ai vu les soldats rouges montée vers
le front j'ai entendu le discours de
staline du catch du 3 juillet j'ai été
je me trouve avoir des témoins aussi
l'étranger dans gaza c'est la grande
guerre patriotique
le mythe de la version devoir
patriotique pris le moule où elle
existait déjà à l'époque de l'invasion
de la russie par napoléon il a ajouté
l'adjectif grand devant et il a fait un
discours dont tous les témoins se
souviennent avec une grande émotion dans
le moindre détail
alors on l'a dit tout à l'heure jean
lopez staline et généraux il étrenne par
vagues successives devant les tribunaux
et les emprisonne et les tortures les
fusils parfois belgique et quelquefois
quand à partir de stalingrad donc si on
est en 42 ans il prend conscience qu'il
en a besoin
oui allez c'est à dire le grand tournant
c'est juillet 42 où ils seront ils
commencent à accepter l'idée que ses
généraux doivent sont en train
d'apprendre et sont en phase
d'apprentissage
ils vont apprendre de leurs ennemis ils
vont aussi mettre en valeur un certain
nombre de choses qui sont propres à la
pensée militaire soviétique
attention tout ça sous un contrôle d'une
férocité absolue mais il va commencer à
faire confiance à une petite équipe
autour de wasilewski antonoff joue kof
ces gens là vont peu à peu avoir le
droit de le contredire dans les formes
bien entendu puis il ya quelque chose
qui trompe pas c'est en premier la
bataille de stalingrad le 9 octobre 42
il lève le contrôle par les commissaires
politiques car jusque là chaque officier
supérieur de l'armée rouge et et
contrôle strictement par un commissaire
politique qui devrait contresigné tous
ses ordres le 9 octobre ce commissaire
politique sont renvoyés les tâches de
pure propagande et n'interviennent plus
dans les opéras donc le meilleur moyen
de sauver sa peau si on était encore
vivant sentant sida les combattre sur le
front et éventuellement de survie oui
sur vous gagnez des villes de gagner
survivre ce qui était vraiment le
difficile dans l'armée rouge de 41 et 42
où les pertes sont les plus importantes
qu'aucune armée dans aucune histoire et
jamais juillet l'état floats ans et des
millions des millions de morts de
disparus
blesséà caroff qui dit vous le citez
d'un livre la grande guerre patriotique
de sa liste à la fois sa gloire et son
infamie c'est son infamie pourquoi et
bien son infamie parce que les nounous
noter - vétérans le tiennent pour
responsables des immenses défaites du
début
ce en quoi ils sont largement appuyés
par les historiens mais en même temps
ils disent tous on peut se demander si
tout autre que staline était en mesure
d'arrêter les nazis même les plus anti
stalinien parmi eux mêmes une elena
bonner la veuve sakharov dit
oui est ce que quelqu'un d'autre
keystone il aurait pu le dire est que ce
pas là qu'est ce qui est arrivé aux fils
de staline il y avait deux fils cartonné
il sourit c'est qu'il sait femme de deux
femmes différentes son fils aîné donc de
sa première femme géorgienne yaakov qui
était vieux temps l'artillerie est fait
prisonnier à l'est de minsk en juillet
il est arrêté il est interné en
allemagne il est mûr se crée quelques
temps puis sera interné au camp de
sachsenhausen oranienburg et au moment
de nos moments de stalingrad quand le
fel marshals police et fait prisonnier
par les soviétiques
hitler fait passer par son ambassade
suédoise quelques mots laissant entendre
que peut-être on pourra échanger le
lieutenant yaakov de gadji league contre
le fait de marshall pelous et mais je ne
sais pas si le mot est apocryphe parce
que je n'ai pas pu le vérifier vraiment
staline aurait dit on n'échange pas un
lieutenant contraint fait marshall et
son fils se donnera la mort en se
précipitant contre les barbelés
électrifiés du corps de sachsenhausen en
1844 à et ils qui retiendra cette mort
secrète jusqu'à la fin par crainte de
représailles contre les prisonniers
allemands d'union civile étaient dans
les discours que vous avez analysé
choisi monsieur maïs est-ce qu'il y en a
la force de certains d'hitler ou
certains de staline chéraute welt
oui bien sûr je voudrais d'abord dire
que le choix des discours incomber à
dominique mongin g préfacé ce livre est
le choix qui a été fait par dominique
mongin des 50 discours est tout à fait
remarquable
bien sûr il y a chercheuse welt des
discours tout à fait remarquer en
particulier les discours où il essaye
d'expliquer à la nation américaine qu'il
va lui falloir bientôt entrer en guerre
c'est tout songer
diplomatique politique que de la dame
née peu à peu une nation qui était
repliée sur elle même et qui n'avait
absolument pas envie de s'occuper des
affaires européennes de peu à peu entrés
dans le combat alors comment c'est avec
un certain nombre d'astuces et même
d'astuces je dirais de caractère très
très domestique
c'est le fameux tuyau d'arrosage vous
savez bien quand roosevelt explique ci a
ainsi à voisins à un incendie chez lui
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
évidemment vous pouvez vous précipiter
mais vous pouvez aussi lui prêter un
tuyau d'arrosage et c'est ce qui est
important selon lui deux d'apporter aux
voisins c'est à dire aux européens
la reine winston churchill vous raconter
tombe très vite sous l'influencé le
charme de roosevelt
parce qu'il en a besoin c'est tout oui
parce que quand on voit leurs échanges
leur comme d'innombrables mais sans
message entre eux c'est une amitié un
petit peu un petit peu obligé
churchill avait pratiquement que des
amitiés utile dans politique et
roosevelt un certain mépris pour sur
tille qu'ils considéraient comme un
animal antédiluvien mais dont il
admirait néanmoins l'énergie mais je
préférais quand même
churchill de gaulle ah oui il était
atteint de gaulle aux phobies et du vin
passe voilée de gaulle pour de la graine
de dictateur pays bas n'a tiqué en
facile on n'était pas bien sûr qu'il le
connaissait parce que quand ils le
voient pour la première fois enfin le
soir il en parle à son fils eliott
alors bien sûr il y en eut du mal du bon
jeu pour changer d'avis
seulement il est quand même bien
brillant cet homme là parce que de
gaulle a époustouflé par sa rhétorique
sa logique et à lorsqu'il sort d'inr
c'est que de gaulle s'est pas aperçu que
vous faites n'avaient pas changé d'avis
sur lui il est très content de lui et il
croit qu'il l'a séduit pas du tout et
alors là justement il admis à il admire
il il est d'autant plus dangereux que il
est infiniment plus intelligent que giro
alors tout à fait d'accord avec vous
finalement sur les dissensions quand
même un peu profonds entre certains de
ces messieurs parce que l'autre sur
celle et roosevelt et à l' empire
parce que quand même vous êtes qu'il est
pas rentré dans la guerre seulement pour
servir du tuyau d'arrosage et couvrir
les européens et les anglais
de bien fait il a quand même quelques
mauvaises intentions en particulier il
ya cette idée qu'il faut supprimer les
empires coloniaux et en particulier
comment préserver le terme giro a
oui parce que il a trouvé giraud
finalement tressos finalement et
inconsistants il a reproché eisenhower
de lui avoir présenté où avez vous
trouvé ce genre d'homme enfin j'ai
jamais vu un homme pareil avec comment
se fait-il qu'en lequel ils sont arrivés
monsieur crémieux brilhac à cacher à de
gaulle même les plans de la campagne de
normandie du débardage vérifiant ans la
méfiance est extrême il y avait une une
hostilité qui était devenu de 207 de
sensibilité mais d'autre part depuis
l'origine il y avait une méfiance à
l'égard des français disent qu'on
considérait comme un discret ça va des
charmantes et à la faire de dakar en
septembre 1940 il est certain que les
indiscrétions vsd commises dans cette
affaire par de gaulle lui même par les
anglais aussi
mais les indiscrétions du de gaulle a
rapporté aux anglais aux américains qui
roosevelt en particulier n'a jamais fait
confiance à développer et quand les
cherchent ils staline roosevelt roosvelt
malades vont se voir et kalach ils ont
découpé la géographie du continent
européen du goal n'est pas là nan nan de
gaulle n'est pas là et toutes les
principales décisions à partir de 41 ans
était prise en dehors de goules de
gaulle d'ailleurs avait marché sur les
pieds des américains en s'installant à
saint pierre et miquelon contre l'avis
de roosevelt ski se pardonnent pas
nationalement et c'est à dire que toutes
les opérations ultérieures notamment le
débarquement en afrique du nord et à
l'insu de bol devant le pas sur de
gaulle roosevelt le duel au sommet
françois kersaudy sur schiele contre
hitler
françois kersaudy victoire fatale en
norvège 1940
quelles sont les premières phrases de
de chercher sur de gaulle quand il le
voit quand il voit le colonel au cours
de ses voyages en france que raconte
d'ailleurs bien roland de margerie il
est très impressionné par de gaulle
c'est le seul qui ne panique pas c'est
le seul qui reste flegmatique qui
ressemble plus aux anglais il faut le
dire et
ils ne s'affolent pas et churchill
certifie et que mardi ce qui n'est pas
tellement étonnant d'ailleurs le 13 juin
se plantant devant de gaulle
il lui aurait dit l'homme du destin est
gentille dame est comme ça les
intuitions foudroyante c'est pourquoi
l'homme du destin parce qu'il avait
besoin d'un homme d'idées cela en france
et que l'étape de france le connétable
france ferraille s'est il avait
impressionné et voit la cia intuition
que c'était alors on a demandé après de
gaulle sicile avait entendu cette phrase
prophétique voit aussi dans un couloir
très encombré où il ya beaucoup de monde
qui paniquait l'oreille du général était
à peu près 20 cm de la bouche de
churchill qui parlait dans un français
un peu macaronique avec un cigare et 1
entre les lèvres donc évidemment qu'il
ai pas entendu ça peut se comprendre les
de gaulle a dit non je n'ai pas entendu
mais vous savez churchill c'est un
romantique
alors évidemment mais le mot faut me go
pourrait être authentique danger croît
quand il était à la fois romantique et
aussi un grand coeur et en même temps il
était fasciné par de gaulle quand même
devant un personnage allait dire de
tragédie je pense à une scène qui est
quand même assez extraordinaire ses
ventes de ces que de gaulle ne voulait
pas aller en fanfare en contre et giro
et voulait pas les rencontres et roswell
non plus donc cherché l'obligent à venir
et puis il le reçoit juste la veille de
l'entrevue dans sa petite dans sa villa
il dispute et de gaulle 120 à travers le
jardin est là
churchill et avec son médecin alors
maurane il et méditatif y regarde de
gaulle s'éloigner la grande silhouette
au milieu des fleurs des armes et ils y
regardez le il a rien je menace de
laisser tomber
et pourtant il se comporte comme staline
avec ses 200 division quel bonhomme vous
en parlez comme si vous y étiez amis ici
même s'il fait car son disciple 43 une
phrase de chercher je comprenais
j'admirais le comportement arrogant du
général de gaulle même si j'en ai prouvé
du ressentiment c'est un réfugié un exil
est condamné à mort pour son pays
entièrement tributaire de la bonne
volonté du gouvernement britannique
les allemands avaient conquis son pays
nul part il était chez lui
qu'importe il bravait tout cela on
disait pour se moquer qu'il se prenait
pour l'incarnation vivante de jeanne
d'arc
je trouvais cela moins absurde qu'il y
paraissait un bel hommage
oui oui alors il a certainement il à
dire il a dit qu'il fallait d'expédier
de gaulle al sour de londres c'était des
coups de colère mais à côté de ça il a
dit quelle magnitude par la gauche et
c'est un grand animal à ce que de gaulle
aurait sans doute mal pris mais quand on
connaît l'admiration on veut chercher
une fois les animaux c'était un immense
compliment et à la fin quand de gaulle
était au pouvoir après les années 50 8 c
il avait reçu chercher l'appareil et il
l'avait traitée magnifiquement la
libération il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'étrangers campe été fait compagnon la
libération et avec des propos
extrêmement élogieux c'est un grand
homme dans une grande entreprise d'une
grande tragédie et le passager terriens
s'aperçoit aussi que churchill a été
pour lui un professeur un maître d'école
et lui a appris la propagande la bonne
propagande
il a appris il va nous rester peu de
temps mais on reviendra sûrement
réaliser un des couples body qu'on n'a
pas évoqué qui sont liés par une
véritable admiration au milieu de la ncc
staline et hitler colisée journal de
québec que belge rapporte des propos
incroyablement élogieux d'hitler
vassa staline et le sol sommes anti
staline et jamais fait confiance dans
toute sa vie lui le grand par ariane
paranoïaque ce adolf hitler en 1941 il a
cru à son alliance pacte germano
soviétique a fait tellement de dégâts
il faut créer d'ici à l'actif de church
et je voudrais rappeler qu'il a été le
créateur d'un service secret qui se
blessent oui services et opérations
spéciales en marge de l'intelligence
service qui a joué un rôle considérable
dans l'action subversive dans toute
l'europe
un mot il ya les décideurs au sommet et
elle est vraie généraux ceux qui sont
sur le front pour hitler on va aller
vite m'en vais en citer quelques-uns
pour hitler sérum elle pas seulement ces
rebelles dont on parle de plus parce que
ils l'avaient sens de la propagande
parce que ils étaient en afrique parce
que les halles les anglais l'admiré mais
il y avait bien d'autres
généralement d'une grande capacité
y'avait von rundstedt j'avais von
manstein daegu derian et tous ses atouts
et toutes ses formes cloud et tous ces
gens là c'était des gens qui avaient été
formés à l'école de guerre qu'ils
étaient des vrais
c'était pas des stratagèmes année la
grande bataille d'el alamein mais
tobrouk benghazi fin des territoires
dont on parle tellement aujourd'hui
c'était trop mal oui c'est vrai mais
c'était c'était très téméraire rebelles
étaient était un brillant stratège
lyonnais serait téméraire c'est à dire
que la logistique ça n'intéressait pas
il s'en occuper pas et de toute façon
elles étaient très fragiles et donc il
est allé très loin au delà de ce que la
logistique lui permettait et de ce point
de vue là évidence c'était quand même sa
faiblesse au sa défaite devant
montgomery voilà c'est vraiment de rien
surtout le tacticien juillet comment il
a fini rebelles oh il a mal fini
rebelles il a mal fini par semer en
forme de grandeur s'est opposé à hitler
non il s'est justement c'est ça qui est
curieux et maintenant on le sait il ne
s'est pas opposé à hitler il n'a pas
voulu faire partie du complot contre
hitler encore andy n'a rien voulu savoir
mais il a couvert ce dont il savait que
il
été mêlé c'est tout mais comme hitler
était aussi paranoïaques que salines il
a soupçonné que romaine en faisait
partie
ce qui n'était pas le cas staline
biographie choses et radine ski aux
éditions du cherche midi et les généraux
américains
monsieur weiss il ya en particulier à un
annuaire alors ice adverse et le type du
général manager parce qu'au fond il ya
deux types de généraux il ya les
combattants on vient de parler de rang
mais les guerriers qui se porte en avant
qui n'hésite pas au moment de la
bataille de se mettre en avant des par
rapport aux combattants et puis il ya
les managers c'est à dire ceux qui
organisent ce qu'ils sont les génies
d'un logistique d'autant plus que cette
guerre est une guerre mondiale avec des
dizaines de milliers d'hommes et de deux
combattants et qu'il faut organiser tous
par eisenhower de ce point de vue là est
un génie de la logistique et de
l'organisation
marchal faut pas l'oublier autres génies
de la logistique et de l'organisation
marshall c'est back tone il avait les
meilleures à celles combattants tous les
jours c'est un grand mot dans son lit
avec un caractère mais un beau portrait
macarthur c'était ces sont des hommes
qui se porte en avant et qui veulent
faire le coup de feu
et puis vous avez des grands stratèges
dont on parle très peu l'amiral nimitz
d'origine allemand granon abri d'origine
allemande à dire vous avez 8 9 parmi les
parmi les les grands généraux et amiraux
américain vous avez des quantités
d'aliments eisen away domicile homme qui
bat le fer ces voix là il était alors
c'est très curieux puisque nimitz ne
parlait pas anglais avant l'âge de 8 ans
il parlait allemand ce qui est quand
même étonnant pour un grand stratège
américain et par contre eisenhower
famille allemande quand même
il a failli échouer westpoint à cause de
l'allemand maik en zone infectée pas
également que ça peut avoir c'est
curieux mais vous avez bien d'autres
rêver de meilleur vous avez je passais
tous de tous ces grands généraux
américain cédant finalement grâce qui
est amusant c'est roger nord américains
ont quand même beaucoup d'idées
politiques sur l'organisation de
certains politiques un peu marshall et
le général de gaulle va finir par donner
l'impression aux français qu'ils ont
tous été des résistants des grands
combattants et vous savez à quel point
de ces très vieux berriac vous qui étiez
là qu'ils étaient plutôt minoritaire
avec eux beaucoup s'étaient accommodés
de la présence allemande déjà dans paris
il ya très longtemps c'est mieux
maintenant que l'esprit entièrement a
été beaucoup plus précoce qu'on ne le
dit ils sont attentistes oui il peut
s'engager
j'ai regardé tous les rapports des
préfets de vichy donc en général un
préfet ça veut faire plaisir à son
gouvernement
finalement tous quand même pratiquement
10 que les gens sont allés coup de la
radio de nom de même si la droite
entièrement et que à partir de 9 ans à
partir après le débarquement en afrique
du nord
il bascule l'administration en partie
bascule affaires étrangères mais ce qui
a eu le garde un certain sentiment qu
est ce qu a eu comme les comportements
elles sont patriotiques
ça va pas beaucoup plus loin le jeune
historien aujourd'hui qui découvrent ce
qu est l administration la préfecture de
police la justice etc et pas très bien
raconté des scènes festives qui ce
qu'ils pensaient si vous voulez au fond
d'eux mêmes alors d'ailleurs on voit
qu'il ya des différences régionales moi
je ne sais pas une des choses qui me
frappe quand je regarde les actualités
au moment de la libération
enfin telles qu'elles ont été tournées
par les américains vous avez quand même
un gros contraste entre la normandie et
la région parisienne en région
parisienne seine l'enthousiasmé délirant
en normandie
c'est beaucoup plus réservé il ya des
régions qui ont des sentiments un peu
différent mais dans l'ensemble on est
patrick les plus deux régions deux
régions réticente dès le début le nord
pas de calais la bretagne le nord pas de
calais qui le disaient l'erreur que
patrick buisson
historien a parfaitement à compter des
années d'occupation et les plaisirs
parisiens de cette époque peut en
profiter mais il y avait à la fois des
slr osisko côtoyaient et puis allez
photos significatives que je recommande
sur cette époque de cécile desprairies
qu'est venu en parler je vous le
recommande
mais tout ce que vous nous révéler sur
un nouvelle histoire de vichy viendra en
parler sans doute ici et monsieur
crémieux brilhac à la rentrée nous dira
ce qu était le combat intérieur s qui a
des leçons à tirer de à la fois de ce
conflit et puis en même temps du fait de
ce qu'étaient les chefs stratégie qui
n'étaient pas des militaires pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
alors on peut donner une version de
churchill aversion de gaulle churchill
dans un petit livre que hitler aurait eu
tout intérêt à lire et qui n'a
probablement pas lui qui s'appelle mes
jeunes années disait il faut jamais
déclenché une guerre parce que après on
n'est plus maître de rien rien à la
guerre ne se passe comme c'est prévu
sauf de temps en temps et par hasard et
donc il faut il faut surtout pas des
granges et zabriskie après on perd toute
maîtrise sur les événements il sera là
pour lui il a eu tort pour ce les leçons
ce qu'on découvre le rôle et les faits
de la psychologie et des caractères bien
sûr qui se révèle aux feux de
les événements pour clémence ou comme
pour churchill la guerre est une chose
trop sérieuse pour être laissée aux
militaires mais ce que pour toi faut la
donner seulement aux politiques qu'ils
soient nés serait la chose militaire non
plus il faut donc cet équilibre nous il
faut bien choisir ses militaires surtout
soutien de tirer des leçons ya du sang
mais aussi peut-être un certain nombre
on a évoqué des choses abominables ou
des choses héroïque mais il ya peut-être
un certain nombre de progrès qui
viennent de cette guerre et qui viennent
de l'horreur elle même quand on découvre
le génocide pour c'est quand même un
traumatisme extraordinaire
et là je me souviens du cas backton qui
est quand même un homme d'un choeur
extraordinaire patton ouvrant le premier
camp de concentration qui l'a libéré est
véritablement bouleversé et il fait
venir à ce moment là le maire de la
petite ville et sa femme et leur fille
visiter le camp de concentration et ce
couple là va se pendre dans la nuit
tellement ils ont de cette horreur on a
tiré quand même quelque chose c'est à
dire qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire de
ces gens-là de ses responsables alors un
moment vous êtes avait dit pour fusiller
140000 etc
et puis on dit non c'est la justice doit
passer et c'est nuremberg c'est quand
même la tentative une justice pour des
conflits d'aujourd'hui de l'est
peut-être que ça donne l'idée qu'il ya
une justice internationale a
perfectionné et que peut-être un peu les
peuples monsieur club il ya se
débarrasse d'une manière ou d'une autre
un jour avec la résistance intérieure ou
de la résistance des dingues qui les
dirigent
exactement c'est ce qu'ils disent moi je
dois encore une autre leçon et ça c'est
une son professeur mais nous sommes pour
un certain nombre d'entre nous sait que
ses hommes ont été cela parce qu'ils ont
une certaine éducation et une certaine
culture le goût de l'héroïsme acquis
dans leur jeunesse est acquis avec
l'enseignement d'histoire le d'accord là
dessus
la plupart des chefs de guerre ont connu
l'ingratitude des peuples une fois le
deuxième conflit mondial terminé
cherchent ils laissent en tout cas dans
ses mémoires et vous le rappeler
françois kersaudy quatre principes
habilité je crois qu'ils traversent les
frontières et les années peut-être vous
en souvenez dans la guerre résolution
dans la défaite
intransigeance dans la victoire
magnanimité dans la paix bonne volonté
c'est pas mal dans la guerre résolution
dans la défaite intransigeance dans la
victoire magnanimité dans la paix bonne
volonté avis à tous ceux qui font la
guerre aujourd'hui qui cherchent à
régler des conflits merci à vous tous
merci vraiment sincèrement vous avez
démontré que vous étiez dans cette
période
et vous l'avez vous fait vivre merci à
tous et à bientôt